a hundred years ago some women you know
fought for the right to vote not you
know then another ten years later all
wearing got the rights of vote and then
we had a reduction in the voting age but
we have a long way to go before we get a
full representation in Parliament and
also before we get full representation
of women in all strands of society it is
all about choices there isn't it being
able to do what you want to do not being
limited by your class or or indeed
indeed by your gender I'm so what what
is your view on the on the grid girl
controversy a hundred years on and from
those first votes were women I mean
those women be allowed to choose the
clothes they wear without censorious
finger-wagging from the left mister
decision that the formula one took in
regards to whether they think his
appropriate in this day and age I mean
my issue was really around the
President's Club and those young girls
and women who were attending were not
attending therefore to be the plaything
of the men who were there and that was
my issue and what I also found
disappointing was that when Labour
introduced the Equality Act 2010 we had
section 40 in there which is a clause to
say that if an employer knows that
there's risk of women going into a
placement it makes it unsafe for them
that they can be held liable and
accountable and as a coalition
government that removed that clause and
I'm fighting tooth and nail to get this
government to reinstate that clause
because that protects women and
vulnerable people who are working but do
you see that the the controversy around
the grid girls and the controversy about
those women who were you know abused at
the president's complex call it what it
is do you see that as of a piece I mean
the point that some people have made
this week including amongst them julie
hartley brewer is that the the left will
defend to the death that the right of a
woman to wear a burka but if she chooses
to wear two rather more revealing outfit
she's a she's a victim who must be
protected from herself I don't think
anybody's artery in that at all what we
argue that women can wear whatever they
choose to wear whatever they feel
comfortable in wearing I mean doing
though that's that's that's the argument
that they make yeah
I mean I'm fine with that and we're fine
with whatever they want to wear the
issue is whether they're being as you
say abused or not whether they're being
exploited and abused they can do a job
that they choose to do that's fine no
one's got a problem with that at all but
it's where it's been exploited that's
the issue know what they're where women
can wear what they want to wear as long
as nobody's telling them what they
should wear so if you turn up to work
and they say you have to wear this
little black dress matching knickers and
high heels that is an abuse because they
are being told they don't select their
own clauses or where there is an outfit
there is a uniform and it's a pretty
skimpy one at that but if they're
choosing to wear I mean if that's their
if that's their decision and they you
know they walk out the house if this is
what they want to wear that's the right
of the woman to wear what she wants to
wear if you're being told you can only
wear this and you don't want to or you
were not aware that that was going to be
the dress code there's a problem and we
had legislation that's the thing that
gets me we had legislation that dealt
with this the coalition government
decided to remove it for what reason the
possible reason indeed I mean another
area in which you're adamant the choice
is central is around transgender issues
you love the opinion that all-female
short lists should be open to to all
self-identifying women why is that the
Labor Party has already shortened this
we're the only party to use all women
shortly so we made sure that the Act was
amended so that we can implement there
so that we can see a change in
Parliament and we've seen a phenomenal
change of the structure and the makeup
of Parliament because of all women short
lists and it's open to all women but I
understand that you'd like many other
people are happy to treat someone as a
women if they do if they saw identify
but why shouldn't there be as some
people within the Labour Party have
suggested some women have suggested why
shouldn't there be at least our legal
requirement that they're legal gender be
female okay oh it's will be shortly so
open to all women and that includes
trans women as well I mean it's really
quite as simple as that to be honest you
don't see that you don't see that the
argument that is made by some that
actually if you if you did
the simple self-identification fine but
the requirement of having your legal
gender is being female to have a place
on the shortlist and there's competition
for places only shortlist huge
competition there and I think this stems
from the gender recognition act and the
fact that they're supposed to be an
amendment to the act we're still waiting
for the government to start the
consultation and have a talk about what
needs to be amended how we modernized
the language and all of that stuff that
is very different from or with me
shortly it's there's talk of you know
other things around safe spaces for
women this there's lots of different
areas that need to be discussed and
ironed out but you know our policies
quite clear and it's and it's been clear
from the very beginning to be honest I
mean we don't it's not something that's
really been a huge issue and we've had
all the me shortlist for decades now you
said in the past that you you don't
think that Teresa Mazur is a feminist do
you think that there are any
conservatives that could be called
feminists there are and the reason why
I'll qualify the reason why I said she's
amazed not feminists because I've seen
86% of this government's cuts fall on
the shoulders of women I've seen women
refugees close down because of lack of
funding I've seen I've seen areas where
women were making progress now I've been
held back because of trees and maize
government so it's not just enough to be
a woman you know you also have to be and
to call yourself a feminist you also
have to you know help progress the
movement take the next steps in regards
to women's rights and women's equality
let's talk about what could potentially
be a very a very big next step foot for
the Labor Party banner strata party said
this just a just a few months ago
regarding the leadership as far as I'm
concerned next time it's a woman my very
strong preference is the Labour Party
should say to itself it's time we had a
woman after Corbin as we head towards
the centenary of some women getting the
vote would you agree with that I'd love
to see a woman leader of the Labour
Party I mean we did have a woman leader
of the Labour Party
we have a dead woman Prime Minister I
mean more importantly I want to see a
Labour government and I want to see a
Labour government as soon as possible
because the damage that this
Conservative government's doing to the
country is sometimes feels like it's
going to be you know take a lot of work
and effort to undo the damage wouldn't
you concede that as things stand the
Labour Party itself has some had some
very real problems with with sexism
clear Cobra resigning as Labour leader
of Haringey Council last week this week
I should say citing sexism and bullying
I mean what's the party doing about that
so I mean Clare has done a phenomenal
job
in Harrogate she turned around the
council is the point getting water
having it I think it's important that
you know I praise the work that Clare
was done you know it's important that I
do that any issues of sexual harassment
racism bullying the Labour Party has
firm robust policies and it's important
that anybody that feels they've been
discriminated against in any way reports
it so they can go through the structure
so there's the party not investigating
this if if there's an investigation I
don't know whether Claire has reported
an investigation of sexual harassment or
bullying I hope that she has because I
think it's important because if if she
has been sexually harassed or bullied we
have to root those people and Jeremy
said time and time again there's no
place in the Labour Party and in these
party for anybody that oppresses anybody
for any reason whatsoever so if she is
you know she needs to report it and it
needs to be dealt with and I for one
will be ensuring that it's dealt with
and probably because we have robust
policies to make sure that this happens
it's mean it's not just it's not just
your labour women who have bad act at
public meetings mean what did you make
of the way in which Jacob be smog was
targeted by self-confessed supporters of
jet of Jeremy Corbyn I mean do you see
any link between what happened there and
you know John MacDonald's repeating
those colleagues comments about lynching
esta McVeigh calling for direct action
against all Tory MPs we Jacob Riis Marg
you know loves free speech he promotes
free speech all the time and yeah I do
as well and so you know he went up to to
talk to these people don't know and I've
seen quite
videos from different angles and they
seem to be having a conversation before
somebody came from behind Jacob Riis
smoked in a white shirt and attacked a
woman which I found very strange and
unsavory and wrong I think the important
thing here is the abuse that politicians
receive free speech is one thing you
know having a disagreement with people's
another thing you know that is fine but
when it comes to abuse as a real issue
when I found out this week that in my
office my office manager now says that
he's the only one who will open the mail
because we get abuse coming through and
he doesn't want any of our interns or
anyone else to read it and I just think
we do have to tackle this issue of of
abuse